le sentier de grande randonnée de
l'iphone sillonnent les paysages
vallonnés de l'ouest de l'allemagne
nous abordons la deuxième partie de ce
périple de 313 km au pays des volcans
éteints depuis gerolsteiner nous
traverserons down manderscheid et
wittlich étape ultime de ce voyage dans
l'iphone trêve
la plus vieille ville d'allemagne
cette contrée de l'iphone est une région
parsemée d'anciens volcans dans ce
massif de l'ouest de l'allemagne
bouillonnait il n'y a pas si longtemps
une infernale fournaise un passé agité
mais à l'origine d'un trésor de la
nature la roche volcanique est le
berceau d'une eau minérale feng et
vivifiante et naturellement gazeuse
c'est à gerolsteiner petite station
climatique est baignée par là qu'il que
nous avons donnés rendez-vous à oliver
bloem il va nous accompagner lors de
cette première étape de notre randonnée
nous faisons le plein avant d'entamer la
balade
premier arrêt mystique une petite
chapelle de pèlerinage est niché dans la
forêt de gerolsteiner
c'est une famille noble de la région qui
l'a fait érigées au xviie siècle pour
avoir eu la vie sauve lors d'une
embuscade la forêt de gerolsteiner était
alors le repère des bandits de grand
chemin
oliver veut nous emmener sur le plus
haut sommet du pays de guer holstein
l'audit sunlights qui culmine à plus de
600 mètres depuis la petite tour
panoramique la vue s'étend sur des
kilomètres sur le massif de l'eifel
et maintenant
non loin de là se dresse le château de
lys single l'un des châteaux forts de
l'iphone les mieux conservées c'est
aussi le lieu de travail de l'hiver il
est maître boulanger et a remis en
service un magnifique four à bois
traditionnelles typiques de cette région
d'allemagne
mais qui dit tradition ne dit pas
forcément méthode archaïque dans le
fournil oliver travaille avec des
instruments bien de son temps
c'est indispensable pour répondre à la
demande d'une clientèle de plus en plus
nombreuses
autant dire qu oliver a plus que du pain
sur la planche le geste du boulanger sur
les ingrédients authentique la levée de
la pâte se fait en deux temps puis
oliver ont fort de les pâtons
les plus anciennes parties du château
date de 1280 mais l'édifice repose sans
aucun doute sur des fondations datant de
l'époque romaine
contrairement à la plupart des châteaux
de l'iphone le château de les singles
n'a jamais été détruits est resté
relativement préservée des dommages du
temps le visiteur fait un véritable
voyage dans le temps dans ces salles
presque intacte la magie médiévale
opèrent au bout de deux heures de
cuisson les miches sont bien dorés
oliver vérifie que le pain est cuit à
coeur le pain de l'hiver est un pain de
campagne rustique à la mi dance et
goûteuse un pain typique de l'iphone
therrien est solide nous avons à présent
rendez vous avec dirk heinz qui veulent
nous faire entrer dans le saint des
saints
la source de l'eau minérale de
gerolsteiner kind et chimistes pour
gerolsteiner brawn
la société des eaux minérales de
gerolsteiner
gisement aquifères sous haute
surveillance dirk heinz procède
régulièrement à des contrôles de qualité
draconien lentement filtrer à travers la
terre volcanique de l'iphone enrichis en
minéraux par la roche dolomitique l'eau
minérale de gerolsteiner accumule goutte
après goutte à 200 mètres sous terre au
moment du pompage
elle est immédiatement acheminés vers la
station d'embouteillage sans étape
intermédiaire qui pourrait la dénaturer
elle revoit le jour
purée intacte dans une bouteille à son
arrivée
l'eau est séparé de son gaz carbonique
précieusement conservés puis elle et des
ferries et pour la préserver de
l'oxydation
le gaz est ensuite réintroduite dans les
mêmes proportions qu'à l'émergence la
société gerolsteiner brunnen est leader
sur le marché des eaux minérales
allemandes
un succès qui s'exporte l'eau minérale
de guerre holstein est distribué dans
plus de 40 pays
mais retournons à présent au grand air à
une dizaine de kilomètres de guerre
holstein s'élève le nez rotor coop
le vestige d'un volcan après des
décennies d'exploitation forestière la
nature reprend peu à peu ses droits
l'homme y est le bienvenu mais doit se
garder d'intervenir
les sols sont jonché d'arbres morts la
végétation pousse à son propre rythme
c'est ainsi que naissent les forêts
vierges de demain nous nous dirigeons
vers down en gravissant les douze pentes
du mont kahlenberg
dan est une petite ville thermale niché
au creux de la vallée de la lys heures
nous y retrouvons à rim google et céline
rheineck deux nouveaux compagnons de
route pour une nouvelle étape qui nous
emmènera jusqu'à manderscheid les
randonneurs chevronnés va nous faire
découvrir quelques unes des plus grandes
merveilles naturelles de l'iphone
volcaniques
le temps est magnifique cette balade
promet d'être des plus agréables
les voici les mares les lacs de cratère
né de la rencontre orageuses de l'eau et
du magma en fusion
il y a dix mille ans de cela le marc de
gamekult est un petit lac bleu nuit
presque noir fréquenté en été par les
baigneurs et canoteurs l'eau est plutôt
froide mais nous ne boudons pas notre
plaisir rives boisées eaux profondes et
scintillante
l'atmosphère est enchanteresse presque
irréel
nous prenons un peu de hauteur sur la
tour de ronde du nom du fondateur de
l'association de l'iphone qui oeuvre
pour le développement et le rayonnement
de cette région d'allemagne les
alentours de down compte deux autres de
ses curiosités géologiques le marc
devins une feld et celui de chalk and mr
une très proches l'un de l'autre
ici les habitants les surnomme les yeux
bleus de l'iphone pour arrimer céline
c'est une source d'émerveillement sans
cesse renouvelé vendredi à berne pour
iphone besoin d'anthony joseph insight
isidore face au bo barry eichengreen
shaft ipad et iphone ipad ni ce week-end
la vallée de la lisère est sans doute
l'un des plus beaux paysages que
traverse le sentier
céline et à rim continuent leur chemin
nous nous décidons de faire un petit
détour nous avons entendu parler d'un
élevage de bobbio particulièrement
réputé situé h trône
et puis une petite étape gourmande ça ne
se refuse pas norbert automne élèves des
boeufs de la fameuse race limousine est
réputé pour sa rusticité sa robustesse
et la saveur unique de sa viande son
cheptel compte une quarantaine de têtes
pour norbert automne il est important
que ces bêtes soit élevé humainement
dans de bonnes conditions
sans compter que le stress affecte la
qualité finale de la viande parce qu'ils
nous tirent dessus
dans son rapport tracfin
le jambon de boeuf fumé c'est une des
spécialités de norbert après avoir
mature et quelques jours les morceaux de
viande sont placés dans un fumoir à
chaud durée du fumage environ trois
semaines
la ferme vend directement ses produits
de charcuterie
c'est martha les pousses de norbert qui
tient la boutique
le jambon de boeuf fumé de norbert
hautaine s'apprécie tel quel en tranches
très fines
prochaine destination manderscheid et
ses deux châteaux forts nous retrouvons
céline et à rim qui achève ici leur
balade le long du sentier de l'iphone
devant l'hôtel de ville
séparés par la l'isr les ruines de
lobber bourg et du niederbourg semble se
défier magnifiques exemples
d'architecturé militaire médiévale il
témoigné de la lutte pour le pouvoir
dans l'iphone au moyen-âge
l'obr bourg appartenait à l'électorat de
trêve et le niederbourg était possession
luxembourgeoise à présent direction
l'est dans la forêt de immo road
nous croisons la route de monique à bord
scheidt et de sylvia et celle de
randonneuses originaire de la ruhr life
elle est leur domaine de randonnée de
prédilection aujourd'hui elles se
rendent au monastère de émeraude
fondée au 12e siècle l'abbaye
cistercienne notre dame de lismore road
est un important lieu de pèlerinage
un des nombreux chemins de saint jacques
de compostelle passe à proximité
l'abbaye est un édifice aux lignes
épurées tout en sobriété en accord avec
les valeurs cistercienne
aujourd'hui 13 moines cisterciens vivent
et travaillent au monastère la prière
commune et l'office qui les réunit sept
fois par jour ora et labora prix et
travail
un précepte que le père stéphane
appliquent tous les jours
le monastère a une longue tradition
d'exploitations agricoles et d'élevage
il possède d'ailleurs un petit étang à
truites dont le pisciculteur axel bord a
la charge
de quoi réjouir les clients du
restaurant de l'abbaye
en effet bien que remplissant une
fonction essentiellement monastique
l'abbaye n'est pas un lieu fermé mais
ouvert sur le monde
la spiritualité et la sérénité qui se
dégage de ces lieux doit être partagée
par le plus grand nombre
l'hospitalité est ainsi une valeur que
les moines ont à coeur de préserver
wolfgang ingert et le chef du restaurant
au menu aujourd'hui et de la truite bien
sûr pour commencer le chef n'a aps le
poisson d'une marinade à base de sauce
worcestershire et de jus de citron
il confectionne ensuite une panière aux
amandes journal
aujourd'hui comme hier les pommes de
terre sont l'aliment incontournable de
cette région de l'iphone
en accompagnement de la truite wolfgang
ils gardent prépare à deux couronnes une
sorte de gâteau de pommes de terre
râpées avec de l'oignon des oeufs du
jambon et de la mie de pain
autrefois le deux couronnes était un
plat conserver surtout pour les fêtes et
les grandes occasions
pendant que le gâteau cuit au four le
chef fait griller la truite dans du
beurre avec quelques gousses d'ail bien
parfumée
truites dans son manteau d'amande
accompagné d'un gâteau de pommes de
terre un plat dont le succès ne s'est
jamais démenti
l'abbaye de hime road a été fondée par
bernard de clairvaux maître spirituel de
l'ordre des cisterciens
en quelques années les moines en ont
fait l'un des centres religieux les plus
importants de l'iphone pour le père
stéphane qui vit au monastère depuis
plus de 40 ans
la beauté de la nature environnante est
la quiétude des lieux sont une source de
recueillement tout aussi importante que
l'enceinte du monastère dans la semaine
mais des tirs 7 jaunes médium comme
tailleur mi-temps nasa merci je suis
darren iliad
le cliché
en écoutant le père stéphane on ne peut
s'empêcher de penser que pour beaucoup
d'entre nous ce retour à soi est l'un
des moteurs essentiels de la marche
aujourd'hui
il est temps de reprendre notre bâton de
pèlerin prochaine à ray rice non loin de
wittlich nous arrivons dans un jardin
plutôt extraordinaire à la faune pour le
moins originale un élégant chalet nous
accueille en bordure d'une forêt de
sapins
nous voici hohwald hôtel sonora
le restaurant du chef étoilé elles
mutilent caisses de la petite tension
familiale elle mathilde grèce a fait un
établissement prestigieux et est parvenu
à force de travail d'obstination à se
hisser parmi les plus grands c'est aussi
un chef respecté de ses employés avec
lesquels il tient à s'entretenir tous
les jours
elles mutilent que s'attelle à la
préparation d'un riz de veau il commence
par faire rôtir quelques champignons son
second et bras droit thomas chance nous
parle de son métier avec passion
on peut remarquer une jolie mousse de
persil viendra rehausser le plat d'un
verre lumineux un cône de spaghettis
savamment enroulée trouve également sa
place sur l'assiette et pour terminer
elle meeting s ajoutent encore une
petite cuillère de sauce aux truffes
l'alliance de deux virtuoses de la
cuisine
à consommer sans modération nous
reprenons notre route sur le sentier de
l'iphone prochaine destination cordelle
dagmar là au chaud c'est petra friedrich
nous accompagne pour un bout de chemin
dans un écrin de verdure se dresse le
château de rammstein datant du premier
millénaire du logis seigneurial qui
s'élevait autrefois sur une hauteur de
25 m il ne reste plus que quelques murs
c'est aujourd'hui une curiosité très
prisé des visiteurs
m
le doux paysages de la vallée de la
qu'il nous accueille à présent un peu
plus haut le sentier de l'iphone
continue en direction du sud dans les
vergers les pommiers sont chargés de
fruits bien mûrs la famille rail shirt
cultive ici une variété de petites
pommes acide d'un rouge éclatant idéal
pour la fabrication du cidre séjour de
récolte à l'aide d'une grande perche les
pommes sont gaulle est une technique que
mathias rail shirt maîtrise à la
perfection les pommes à cidre diffère
des pommes de table de par leur
concentration en tanins et leur acidité
quelques rails shirt a planté ses
pommiers avec son mari et les a vu
grandir le fixe c'est le nom qu'on donne
au cidre dans l'iphone avec billy la
cidrerie de marc conrad travail avec les
exploitants locaux qui lui apporte
directement leur production
juste après la récolte
les fruits sont triés lavés et broyer
afin d'en extraire le jus
lorsque la saison du cidre bat son plein
ce sont près de 400 tonnes de pommes qui
sont transformés ici 100 kg de pommes
donne environ 70 litres de jus
le mou est ensuite placé dans des cuves
où il va fermenter pendant six à dix
semaines
le contrôle de la fermentation est fait
par sue tirages successifs à 0 feed
le résultat semble à la hauteur je
prodigue en europe et en afrique
sous le soleil d'hiver les champs de
colza sont si lumineux que d'aghmat
répétera n'ont pu s'empêcher d'aller les
voir de plus près
non
et
nous sommes presque arrivés à trèves
baignée par la moselle
mais avant d'aller rendre visite à la
doyenne des villes allemandes
nous faisons une petite halte à pfahl
seul au cluster shenk un restaurant
traditionnel
le chef christian tenner s'occupe d'un
magnifique sandre pêché dans la moselle
il pratique de petites entailles
régulière sur la peau du poisson pour
éviter qu'ils ne se replie sur lui-même
lors de la cuisson
le sandre est un poisson qui se marie à
merveille avec la choucroute
elle est brièvement revenue dans l'ue
sindou puis mouiller d'une bonne rasade
de riesling dans un morceau de tissu fin
christian tenner confectionne un petit
sac dans lequel ils disposent des grains
de poivre des baies de genièvre et du
laurier il refusera doucement dans la
préparation
il coupe ensuite des pommes de terre
cuites et du boudin de trêve en petits
morceaux qu il enroulé dans une feuille
de brick
et pour lier la choucroute
rien de mieux qu'un peu de pommes de
terre râpées traditionnel petit mais
true grit n'a 14 le bo les filets de
poisson sont passés dans la farine et
poêler les rouleaux de pommes de terre
et de boudin sont plongés dans un bain
d'huile
la cuisson ne prend que quelques minutes
christian jenner n'a pas son pareil pour
réinventer les grands classiques
sur la terrasse du restaurant
l'atmosphère est toute méditerranéenne
christian zenner et son ami christiana
ne peuvent s'accorder que peu de temps
libre mais ils ne renonceraient pour
rien au monde au plaisir d'une petite
balade dans les sous bois
à fonctionner 25-13 n'est plus qu'à 5 km
la ville est un concentré de culture et
d'histoire d'abord siège du pouvoir
impérial romain puis l'un des grands
centres du christianisme primitif et
enfin une ville médiévale dynamique elle
a su garder de précieuses marques
architecturales à l'image de la
remarquable cathédrale saint-pierre
devant la porta nigra nous terminons
notre voyage le long d'un des plus beaux
sentiers d'allemagne le sentier de
grande randonnée de l'iphone